in reality mark ruffalo looks a whole  lot smaller and less green with his  whole body and face being tracked with  cameras in order to be replaced by the  hulk we see on screen  the epic cap versus cat battle involved  a whole lot of practical effects cgi and  of course a stunt double in place for  chris evans in the fight all the effort  was well worth it dr strange traveling  through portals is out of this world but  without the added effects it's oddly  anticlimactic tom holland never fails to  impress as spider-man but luckily behind  the scenes he wasn't facing so much  danger  josh brolin may not have had the power  of the infinity stones to work with yet  he still makes this scene look fantastic  robert downey jr's performance brings  this emotional moment to life in a way  that feels just as intense behind the  scenes scarlett johansson may have been  running alone in the studio but she  totally convinced us she was terrified  with the hulk on her tail